It's so lovely to see you again.
After that ferocious
feline chased you off,
I never thought you'd leave
your country cottage.
>> Hm, yes, I don't much care for
the city, but
I really needed to buy
some Stilton cheese.
>> The country mouse is on the something,
cities allow for
large markets that provides specialized
products, like gourmet cheese.
>> You can't buy fancy cheese, or
much else that's good in the country.
>> No, no, I've got Amazon Prime,
I can order almost anything else online.
>> Amazon Prime is a great
example of how transportation and
logistics can deliver a wide range of
products across America and the world.
>> You can't sample cheeses when shopping
online, and there aren't great specialized
services, like whisker waxing
salons out in the country.
>> But when I order online,
I can avoid the crowds.
I hate lines and I hate traffic.
>> The average commute time for
a New York City resident is 40 minutes.
The average commute time in
Montana is just 18 minutes.
>> I just listen to music
when I'm stuck waiting.
>> Well I have a short commute and
I can hear the crickets at night.
>> True, you don't have to deal with
traffic, but jobs pay more in the city.
>> On average, wages go up by about 5%
as metropolitan area density doubles.
>> Sure, you make good money,
but what about housing?
I'd never pay such sky high rent.
>> Housing prices also typically go
up by about 5% as metropolitan area
density doubles.
>> Yes, but I have the best museums,
shows, and restaurants.
>> This cafe is very nice.
>> City dwellers basically share the fixed
costs of supporting a variety of cultural
institutions.
Urban density also
increases the bump rate,
the chance of meeting someone new and
exciting.
>> But cities are dangerous.
>> I always feel safe in the city,
there are so many eyes on the street.
>> Crime is an unfortunate
reality in American cities, but
most have become a lot
safer since the 1980s.
In fact, New York City has a lower
murder rate than the country as a whole.
>> And really the best thing about
cities is the endless novelty.
The new opportunities, the new ideas,
the new rodents, it's all so exciting!
>> Give me my warm, safe cottage any day!
>> Okay, but while you're visiting,
wanna catch a show?
You know, Cats is playing!
[MUSIC]